hello everyone and welcome to a really
fun game that was played in 2013 that's
already 10 years ago between myself and
they feed a master from a city next to
mine uh Pavo keglovich he's a not just a
feeding Master but he's also a grand
master of Correspondence chess and they
and the true gentleman uh as I have met
him many times he's uh really an
incredible player an incredible person
and always has a lot of fun uh stories
to share and um this is the first time I
faced such a strong opponent he was at
the time we played this he was 72 years
old he's 83 now and he's still an active
chess player so he's still very strong
mentally and physically but at the time
we played this game he was 72 but
probably in better shape than than I was
uh so I I didn't expect much from this
game and I was very very well I was
almost scared going into this game
because I've never faced a title player
I've Faith some candidate Masters but
never never he feed him faster so I was
I already psyched myself out maybe
before the the game started but uh I
actually managed to do something in the
game it's not a lot I did not play a
good game I did not play a great game
the moves you will see here uh you've
you've probably never played such such
bad moves uh but um you know a series of
bad moves kind of kind of created a a
something so it's it's hard to describe
without me actually showing it to you so
let's check it out
um it was played in 2013 in the Regional
Championship I had a wide pieces and I
opened the game with E4 as I usually do
we have pawned the C5 and Knight to F3
and here he played Pawn to E6 uh which
um okay I I knew about this move I knew
this move existed but if I studied
anything it was the uh how to attack the
Knight of Cecilia and I never I really
did any research on how to plug in spawn
to E6 okay I played Pawn to D4 and you
had to open up the center now to F6 I
played Knight to C3 and here he played
Ponte E6 which is uh from today's
standpoint a very very rare move as it
invites Ponte E5 and even though I was
an aggressive player I I would attack at
the the first chance you give me uh I
did not play this I I have no idea why
uh probably I I thought he was bad since
he was a feeding Master uh but yeah yeah
after E5 he would have to go back or
maybe Knight to D5 and then he allows
the trade and he allows the doubling of
the pawns but maybe he can just go back
and then maybe my Pawn is not as strong
here as as I think it would be so it's
hard to say the engine says it's fine uh
you're gonna play something like Bishop
to F4 continue with Queen to D2 maybe
Castle Queen side I thought maybe it was
a bit too ambitious to try this so I
played Bishop to G5 now I prepare I'm
preparing Pawn to E5 and he played Queen
to C7 uh I played Queen to F3 uh just
continuing my development uh trying to
Castle Queen side and Bishop to seven
now I did Castle Queen side here and he
played Knight to C6 put pressure on my
knight here and I did not want trade uh
I I I should probably just continue
development but I played Knight to B3 I
wanted to keep the pieces on the board
uh and also uh uh the Knight on B3 is
preventing the queen from coming to A5
in the future which I thought could be
could be uh irrelevant so uh he starts
spawn to B5 as we do have castles on
opposite sides of the board he still
hasn't Castle his King is still on E8 uh
but still uh could be it could be very
relevant and now I should start with a
nice prophylactic King to B1 but I start
my attack with Pawn to G4 probably
thinking okay he's gonna cast I'm gonna
push G5 H for H5 and so on uh but the G4
is already a bad move in itself because
it kinda uh uh well it it kind of
exposes not only the the G4 Pawn but
also this diagonal uh which you'll see
how he takes advantage of this he plays
Bishop to B7 seven
uh makes sense putting the the bishop on
this long diagonal I play Bishop
captures on F6 he plays Bishop captures
and F6 and now I played Knight to C5 I
was hoping to get rid of this bishop on
B7 uh probably uh the reason why I put
my knight to B3 maybe I was expecting
Bishop to B7 and then I wanted to play a
knight to C5 to put pressure on the
bishop and this is where the fun really
starts here my position is dead lost uh
and you will quickly see why he plays
Knight the E5 he attacks my queen and
also my knight on C5 is hanging so
naturally I have to defend it but in
order to defend it I have to give up the
G4 Pawn so this is what I play Queen to
E3 uh every other move loses terribly
this move also loses maybe just not as
terribly and now if I can play F3 I will
be very happy but of course he's not
gonna allow that he plays Knight
captures on G4 I play Queen to D2 uh the
only move I found if I hadn't found this
move I would probably just resign here
so I played Queen to beat a queen to D2
uh and now uh he played Queen captures
on C5 but not really uh Queen captures
and C5 would be a nice move but if he
goes for that I can play Queen captures
on D7 and after King to f8 I can play
Queen captures on B7 which seems like uh
okay now uh maybe it's white was better
uh but actually after getting the Rook
to safety Rook the E8 uh there's really
not all that much for me to do here I
can basically just resign uh df2 Pawn is
hanging the Knight here is a really just
terrible B4 is coming this is uh uh
completely winning for uh for black so
uh that's one thing you could do another
thing you could do uh is try something
like maybe bishop to E5 which is a very
nasty threat now of of just Bishop to F4
uh winning the White Queen and then I
could play maybe something like Knight
to D3 attack the bishop guard the F4
square but now B4 comes and it's
definitely not easy I would have to play
something like Knight they do he could
capture on e4 and my position is just
the garbage here I mean my Rook is
hanging and I have to Rook to G1 uh I
can play Bishop capture something he can
play Bush characters on D3 and if a
capture on G4 he just goes back and he
has this amazing Queen on C C7 The Rook
is coming to see the Bishops uh are
absolute Monsters uh so there there's no
way I survived this he can just you know
push those pawns and it resigns for me
uh but okay after this uh G4 move this
weird move that I played he first played
Knight the Eve sorry and that's that uh
in in this position uh uh after Knight
to E5 uh I've played Queen to E3 and now
he played Knight captures and G4 like we
said Queen to D2 and now he played Rook
to d8 so he did not go uh for uh either
of the moves that we've mentioned uh
which is also fine but it kinda allows
me to stay in the game a little bit
longer I played Knight captures on B7
and he played Queen captors on B7 and
now I played Pawn to F4 trying to get
those Pawns of the board but his attack
is just much faster Pawn to B4 he chases
away my knight I play not Knight back
the B1 or Knight to A4 I actually played
Knight the D5 here and here I was I was
already uh
preparing myself for resignation but
still I've seen Knight to D5 you know in
books I've seen people play it against
the Sicilian sometimes it works out and
uh you know I I you still
um in those days at least I I still
wasn't used in thinking in engine terms
uh it's not like okay now and now if you
put this to an engine the engine says
okay black is winning it's just a minus
four or minus 3.6 uh but in those days I
thought okay maybe maybe I I have
something here and okay he played e
captures on D5 and now I played H3 just
uh stalling here uh attacking the Knight
he played Knight back to H6 and I played
Pawn to E5 just harassing his Bishop a
little bit he played Bishop back to E7
and I played Rook to G1 just putting my
Rook on the on the G file uh saying that
okay now if if he castles maybe I can
play something like F5 maybe I can put
pressure on the king maybe First bishop
to D3 and then F5 I know I have nothing
but maybe you know if I can get F5 than
F6 maybe
I can I can turn things around but he
just played Bishop to C5 he attacks my
rook and invites me to play Rook
captures on G7 which I do Rook captures
on G7 and now he plays Knights the F5
and it seems like okay now I really have
to resign my Rook is hanging and also he
now gains control of the E3 Square
Bishop to E3 will uh capture my queen
and also I can't go back with Rook to G3
the Knight is also covering that so I
play something really weird I played
Queen to G2
uh this stops Bishop to E3 uh from from
winning my queen and also I'm inviting
him to capture on G7 so I can play Queen
captures on G7 and sort of continue my
attack and while he can do this uh he
goes Rook uh King to fade he now says
all right now you move the rook and
there's nothing for you here I mean
you're just down too much material your
position is absolute uh garbage uh you
you just have to resign here but I still
keep going I play Rook characters on F7
my uh whole idea is a queen to G5
followed by Queen to F6 and maybe good
things will happen that like that's
literally what I was thinking here he
played King characters on uh F7 I played
Queen to G5 and now I'm threatening to
capture his Knight and the problem here
is uh at least for him I believe uh the
time format the time format was um one
hour each so 60 minutes each zero uh
zero increment so there was no increment
if you drop it below the five minute
mark you you have to be really really
careful in order not to get flagged so
here uh after this uh move he played
Knight to E7 and this is not the way to
uh to go uh here you you have to play
something like Rook H to f8 you give up
the Knight you get your king to safety
and that's it let's say queen captures
on F5 with checking G7 Queen to G5 check
into h8 and now okay I can play
something like F5 and it looks like my
my my pawns are nice maybe I do have
something uh but still he's up a full
Rook um it's very very unlikely that I I
will be able to to do anything here
uh for example
if I do play F6 he can just play D6 uh
The Queen Is Now preventing Checkmate
and even though it looks nice there's a
there's really nothing there so uh
that's uh that's one way to do it but
okay after Queen to G5 he played Knight
to E7 like I said the problem for him
was the uh most likely the time format
it was over 10 years ago so I I don't
really remember uh but I imagine uh that
would have something to do with it and
now I played Queen to F6 with check he
played King to G8 and he was in this
position I moved 25 that we agreed to a
draw uh as it it does appear that
there's nothing here for for him to try
anymore and it's a shame because he was
absolutely winning the entire game and I
was just you know Finding like hanging
by a thread the entire game finding move
move uh like I mean I I played
absolutely disgusting moves what I've
played but in the end it somehow worked
out here uh he agreed to a draw because
uh what do you play here uh for example
Queen to G5 would check how do you play
this uh if you go King to F7 I just
repeat if you go King to f8 I just play
Queen to F6 check and now threaten to
pick up your Rook you have to go back
King to G8 and then I just repeat uh so
obviously that's not happening and
instead if Queen to G5 check uh you play
something like Knight the G6 this is
possible but then you have to give up
The Rook on d8 and then I will capture
this with check you will play King to F7
now I will play Queen to F6 with check
and not after something like King T8 I
will play Bishop to D3 threatening to
pick up the Knight that's defending the
Rook here so you have to play Rook to f8
now I'm gonna capture with check captors
captures and you will get this position
King 38 I will play F5 and yes black is
up a full uh full piece but I have the
past F Pawn I have the past H Pawn uh
you know with with little time on the
clock uh it's a very hard to play this
black is object relatively completely
winning here uh but uh you know maybe
not something that any anyone would go
for so I think it's uh it's actually in
the in the situation that it was where
we were playing without increment that
it was um
uh the the correct decision I don't know
uh if he actually uh offered a draw here
or maybe it was a three-fold repetition
like maybe I play Queen G5 check and
then we just continued like this maybe
it was something like this uh but either
way uh we did not uh continue to game
past this point and now uh I I remember
at the time uh maybe this was even the
first round of the tournament I was I
was so proud of myself for for drawing
against the fide Master uh I was so
happy I completely sucked for the rest
of the tournament I wasn't great in this
game but I don't know it uh I I did not
play a a very good tournament but I was
so proud of this game and uh just how I
uh even though I I had a really really
terrible position from very early on in
the game I kept finding moves that sort
of kept me in the game like this queen
to E3 uh I I saved the Knight and then I
find Queen to D2 sort of offering the
night for Queen captures on D7 uh which
is still perfectly fine for him then I
find the after this I play Knight to D5
I know absolutely disgusting then H3
then E5 then Rook G1 then captures and
now after Knight to F5 uh he probably
wasn't even in his wildest dreams that I
would continue past this point because
the Rook is hanging and Bishop to E3 is
coming and then I give up the full Rook
uh not the full Rook but the exchange
and then after this even Rook captures
on F7 and I was somehow able to uh to
survive uh this game so a really really
incredible that that I did not lose this
uh but this is uh how my first game
against the feeding Master turned out
and uh I don't know I I don't I know
it's a terrible game and
um uh
it's not nothing special uh but it's uh
one of the games that I'm uh proudest
the the the the proudest of of playing
because uh
I don't know I I I I it was so so uh
hard for me to even imagine that I would
not lose this game I was going into it I
was already prepared to lose and I was
just finding moves that you know uh keep
me hanging by a thread and in the end
when I finally got the draw I was uh and
absolutely incredible experience for me
and um uh it's it's incredible that he
that that also he even uh offered the
draw uh probably if he continued he
probably would have beaten me but uh he
was just uh
a a fine gentleman uh uh and uh he he
still is uh we've played a couple of
times even after that game and if if he
has like an equal position he will offer
a draw uh even though he he would
probably Crush you uh because he is I
mean an incredibly strong player uh but
yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it also a fun story about Mr Mr
Pavel uh at one point I think maybe it
was some eight years ago maybe seven
years ago I don't know uh we were
playing A Team Championship uh our our
town or our club from our town against
their Club from their town and we came
to their club and Mr Mr Pavo was uh
sweeping the the pavement uh uh you had
to cross the street go on to the
pavement and then you go into their
chess club and he was sweeping the
street and uh you know uh a gentleman
asked him like uh Pablo you're a
professor where are you sweeping the
street and he he responded uh because
it's dirty and I was just like wow what
what what
a great guy incredible stuff I I was so
amazed by this answer that it's actually
something I I try to live by as ever
since I've heard it because it's so uh
so inspiring like there's no I mean you
don't have to have a reason like if it's
dirty you can just clean it and I mean
it was uh to me it was absolutely
incredible uh so yeah that's the game uh
I hope you guys enjoyed I hope I hope
you I didn't disgust you too much with
the moves I played but uh you know I was
I was rated around maybe 1650 at the
time I played this game and uh Power was
maybe 22 50 2300 so like I said it was
beyond my wildest dreams to to get more
than a loss here and uh well this just
made my entire tournament even though as
I remember I played a really really bad
tournament uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it never never
give up even if even if you even if this
is your position like uh Knight F5 was
played even if this is your position
never give up uh you know you still
might survive I would like to thank
bullet king
um Lindley brenza Anonymous and Joyce
Roseman for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing the uh coverage of everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day